Great. How's everyone doing?
Fantastic.
Oh, that's uh better than I thought
people would be doing.
For me, um I don't know. I've been I'm
lucky to have a yard during this uh
shelter in place here in California and
I'm lucky to
uh be able to to spend some time outside
in my yard and I've been messing around
in the garden and at first I thought,
you know, I wasn't really into
gardening, but I've been having a lot of
a lot of fun actually. So, and learning
so much about my own yard, all this
stuff that I never knew about this place
I live. It's great. I'm like lifting up
rocks and seeing worms under them and
sharing that with my daughter and uh
feel like a little kid.
All right,
so
um today we're going to talk about the
Chandandy Lamport algorithm. We're going
to wrap up our discussion of Chandandy
Lamport. Uh
[clears throat]
I have not found any slugs in my garden
yet. I found worms and other critters,
like a caterpillar or two, but I I don't
have slugs, I don't think. Maybe like a
snail.
All right. So, so last time last time we
went over the Chandandy Lamport snapshot
algorithm, we worked out an example in
detail. Um today I I want to finish our
discussion of it uh by talking a little
about the bigger picture um and the
assumptions the algorithm makes and and
uh also a little bit more about what
this uh what distributed snapshots are
are even good for. Um so
um
one so so so one thing that we assumed
right is that there's this there's this
notion of of channels right and that
channels uh channels have fifo behavior.
So so what what is a channel? Well, it's
a connection from one process to
another. And normally uh when we draw
lamport diagrams, right, we just kind of
we there's not any special notation that
we use to say that one process is
connected to another. Um we just kind of
assume that they are, right? So these
processes are sending messages to one
another and there's nothing that we have
to say that says, "Oh, by the way,
process one can send a message to
process two." uh we just assume that
messages can go back and forth between
all these processes however they want
and we don't have an explicit word for
the thing that the the messages travel
through. But in the system model that we
use for talking about the Chandandy
Lamport algorithm uh we had an explicit
name for that thing and that name was
channel. Uh and not only that but
channels imposed this this limitation on
how messages travel through them. um uh
channels impose FIFO ordering on
messages that travel through them. So um
so if this is process A and this is
process B um and we have like message
one and message two
then right now in the channel from A to
B
um that that channel currently contains
message one followed by message two in
that order. So the channel is a sequence
uh uh it's it's ordered and so if if
process A sends message one and then
they send uh message two along that
channel they have to arrive in that
order uh because that's what a channel
is. Um we talked about that last time.
Well it turns out that this this
assumption that messages get delivered
in in FIFO order is a requirement for
the Chandandy Limport algorithm to work
correctly. Um so if you have a setting
where FIFO anomalies can happen then
you're not satisfying the prerequisites
to run the algorithm. So one thing you
might ask is well can you take a shap a
snapshot in those uh in those kinds of
settings if you have a setting where
FIFO anomalies can happen is there some
other choice of snapshot algorithm to
use
uh so there are snapshot algorithms that
don't assume FIFO channels um but those
uh those algorithms might have other
drawbacks um for example one really nice
thing about the Chandandy Lamport
algorithm is that it can run at the same
time as the application is running and
the application messages can keep on
doing their thing and being sent uh even
as the snapshot is taking place. Um so
some other snapshot algorithms don't
have that nice property. Uh and so you
can have this mixture, right? Like let's
say that this is a um an an application
that's running uh right in the middle of
this of of this application running um a
process could decide to start uh
snapshotting itself. uh and then send
marker messages and then this would be
uh this is this is a nice property of
the Chandandy Lamport algorithm that
these these uh marker messages can be
mixed in uh with the with the um
application messages
and my understanding from the literature
on this topic is that if you want to
allow non-FIFO
messages or if you want excuse me if you
want to allow non-fo channels
um then you have to pause application
processes sometimes. So with Chandandy
Lamport, you don't have to do that. Um
so that's a trade-off, right? Um you can
either impose this FIFO requirement uh
and then not have to pause anything or
you could not impose the FIFO
requirement and then maybe have to pause
things in order to take a snapshot.
So that's one of the assumptions that we
make.
channels are FIFO.
Um, what other assumptions do do we have
to make uh in order to run the Chandandy
Lamport algorithm uh and expect it to
work?
We started to talk about this a little
bit last time.
Yeah. Okay. So, reliable delivery. Yeah.
Um,
reliable delivery of messages so
messages aren't lost.
Um, and then we also kind of along with
that we assume other things. uh we
assume that uh no Byzantine behavior
happens, right? We assume that messages
aren't corrupted. Um and we also assume
that messages aren't duplicated. So um
no message loss,
corruption
or duplication.
Anything else we have to assume?
We haven't really started to talk about
uh about fault models yet. And so um I'm
thinking ahead to when we start to talk
about fault models.
Uh so one of the kinds of of faults that
we're going to talk about is processes
themselves crashing. Um so that's
another assumption that being that's
being made here.
So some distributed algorithms are
robust to some number of the processes
in them crashing while they run. Uh but
this is not one such algorithm.
So you might wonder uh if this is kind
of a crappy distributed algorithm if it
can't stand up to these things like
process failure or message loss. Um but
it was the first distributed snapshot
algorithm and it was groundbreaking at
the time. Um and it does hold up even if
messages are arbitrarily delayed. Uh
which is a pretty big deal. Um okay so
these are assumptions that the algorithm
makes or if you like their limitations
of the algorithm. Um but just so that
things aren't all doom and gloom. Um
let's talk about some good things about
this algorithm. Um so we talked a little
bit about termination last time briefly.
Um so so just to talk about that again
just very quickly. Um this algorithm is
guaranteed to terminate. uh and we're
not going to put forth a formal argument
or a formal proof of proof of that, but
just just to informally discuss why we
know it terminates. Well, okay. So, what
does it have to do, right? It has to
record the state of every process and it
has to record the state of every
channel. Um, and every process is
responsible for recording its own state
and the state of its incoming channels.
So if you can argue that that terminates
for every process if if every process
can have its own piece of the algorithm
terminate then it follows that the whole
thing terminates.
So do we know that that terminates?
Yeah, it does. Um so recording its own
state is is pretty straightforward. Um
and then recording the state of its
incoming channels given these
assumptions, right, that messages aren't
lost. Um, we know you're you're going to
get a first marker message. You record
your own state. Um, and then when you
record the state of your incoming
channels, you know, you're going to
receive a marker of you're going to
receive a marker message on all your
incoming channels sooner or later. Um,
so basically once everybody receives a
marker on every one of their incoming
channels, um, then you're on the way to
being done, right? and we know that
everyone receives a marker on all its
incoming channels uh because that's how
the algorithm works and we're assuming
reliable delivery. Um so that's the
informal argument for this happening.
So in their paper, Chandandy and Lamport
say
um if the communication graph is
strongly connected and at least one
process starts, right? At least one
process begins by recording its state,
then all processes will record their
states in finite time. Uh assuming
reliable delivery. Um so when they say
the communication graph is strongly
connected um they mean that every
process is reachable from every other
process um via channels and we have we
have been assuming that that's true
we've already assumed that there's a
channel between every two processes. Um
so in fact in our case um the
communication graph uh is not only
strongly connected it's actually a
complete graph. So if our to draw a a
picture of our processes as if they were
a graph,
uh we've been assuming that every
process has a channel uh with every
other process to and from. So we've been
assuming that the the graph of processes
uh where processes are nodes and and
channels or edges in the graph, we've
been assuming that it looks like this.
Um
so Chandandy and Lampport only say that
the communication graph has to be
strongly connected. So they say you
could have something like this.
Let's say
and this would be um you could you could
simulate this one up here. So this one
is a complete graph.
This one is not complete
but strongly connected.
So if you had something like the bottom
one that's strongly connected, uh you
could simulate this one up here. Like if
you needed to send a message from P3 to
P2, you would have to go around uh
through P1.
Uh so this up here is actually uh the
only one that they require for the
algorithm. But when we talk about the
algorithm uh we kind of just assume that
we have or excuse me I mean they this is
what they assume. Uh uh this is what
what the Chandandy Lamport algorithm
assumes.
But when we talk about it uh we make the
simplifying assumption that we have a
channel between every two processes.
Okay. So,
we're not actually going to do a proof
that the algorithm terminates, but but
if you're unconvinced, I encourage you
to go think about it on your own. Um,
there's an interesting thing uh that I
that I want to talk about next uh with
this algorithm. So, um what Chandandy
and Lamport say is they they say that at
least one process has to start by
recording its state, right? So I think
it's very interesting that they said at
least one right um they didn't say it
had to be one they said it had to be at
least one has to begin uh by recording
it state and that's the initiator
process that we talked about last time
so of course there has to be one right
obviously in order for the algorithm to
run it has to start somewhere um uh but
it's very interesting that they say that
it doesn't have to be exactly one it has
to be at least one um so the in the
examples that we worked through last
time We picked one particular particular
initiator process um to be the one to
record its state first and send out
marker messages. But what if more than
one did that? Um what if multiple
processes said at the same time, okay,
I'm going to start taking a snapshot
now. Would that be okay? And and so the
answer is yes. Um so just as an example
um if we had P1 and P2
processes one and two and they both
decided to initiate a snapshot at the
same time. So let's say that process one
had some events,
process two has an event and let's say
they both decide to initiate this the
Chandandy Lamport snapshot algorithm at
the same time. So process one snapshots
its state
and it sends out a marker message
process two snapshots it state
and it sends out a marker message.
Okay, so they've both sent markers to
each other.
So, recall that um when you're Let's
make this a little bit more interesting.
Let's let's add a message here as well.
We'll call this D.
So, recall that when you're an initiator
and you record your state, you have to
set up markers before you do anything
else. Um, so, uh, so in particular, P2
here has to send out this marker message
right here after it records its state.
So, when it recorded its state, event D
hadn't happened yet. And then it had to
send out the marker message before event
D could happen.
Okay, so good so far. When they send out
their markers, they start recording
their incoming messages. Okay. So now
process 2 um can after it's sent out its
marker here, it starts recording. So
this is the point right here where it
begins recording.
Um so now it records this incoming
message um from B to D on channel C12.
So
message from B to D becomes part of its
uh this channel history.
Um, then they each get each other's
markers, right? And then they can each
stop recording. So C21's channel state
ended up empty
because it didn't receive any messages
while it was recording.
And now we have a complete snapshot.
Is it a correct snapshot?
Yes, it actually is. uh it corresponds
to a to a what we call a consistent cut
uh which we'll talk about uh in a
minute. So is there any way that we
could have ended up with a bad snapshot
here? Um like if P1 and P2 had both
initiated the snapshot
um could you have ended up with
something wrong? So an example of
something wrong might be like if this
looked like this and then C and D
So this would be a bad snapshot here.
Um so what's wrong with this? Um what's
wrong with it is that D is in the
snapshot but B which happened before D
is not. Um so this is a bad
snapshot.
Could you end up with this if both
process one and process two initiated at
the same time? No, you couldn't because
after P1 takes its snapshot here, it has
to send its marker message to P2 before
doing anything else. And that message
can't do this,
right? It can't cross over like this
because of FIFO delivery. Um, so in this
case, process 2 would have to get the
marker message somewhere up here,
somewhere between C and D. And what do
you have to do when you get your first
marker message? You have to record your
state. So the picture would have to look
like this over here. It would have to
look like this instead.
So it would have to correspond to to um
to what we call a consistent cut. So
it's actually fine to have multiple
processes initiate. And this is huge.
Why why is it such a big deal that
multiple processes can initiate this
snapshot algorithm uh and it'll still
work?
So, here's why I think it's a big deal.
What if that wasn't true? What if it
wasn't the case that multiple processes
could initiate at the same time like
this and it would still work?
Well, then suppose that somebody wanted
to take a snapshot, right?
they would have to go around to
everybody and say, "Hey, I'm going to
take a snapshot now. Is that okay?"
And then what if while it's waiting to
hear back from everybody to tell them
that it's okay, what if it gets a
message from one of them saying, "Hey,
I'm going to take a snapshot." And then
things get really chaotic, right? So
what it boils down to is if it's not
okay for multiple processes to initiate
a snapshot at the same time, then the
processes will need some kind of way of
deciding who will initiate. And it turns
out that that in and of itself is a
really is a case of a challenging
class of problems called agreement
problems in distributed systems which
we're going to talk about more uh later
in the course. Um but because this
algorithm works just fine with multiple
initiators, it turns out um we don't
have to worry about any of that. So
processes don't have to agree on who
will initiate. Uh if they want to
initiate, they just go ahead and do it.
Um so there's a question in chat uh
which is do the marker messages have to
include an identifier uh for the
snapshot initiator? Um so I don't think
so. Um because I I mean it who cares,
right? Like if you get uh um if the
algorithm here is running right and this
process initiated and so did this one.
They both sent out their marker
messages. Um I don't think process one
cares that this marker message uh
originated from a different initiator. I
think the algorithm still works fine
without that. I don't recall it there
being anything in the Chandandy Lamport
paper about there needing to be
a a an initiator identifier on these
marker messages. I think the marker
messages can just be undifferentiated.
So yeah, go ahead.
Uhhuh.
Yeah.
Um
uh okay. So right. Okay. So, so right
here the question is does process one
know um so if process one doesn't know
whether this is a marker that's a
response to its marker or whether it's
uh
okay on pro let's okay let's say on
process two um so process two doesn't
know whether this message coming in here
is a response to its marker message uh
or not um Okay, but it Okay, so let's
say it does close this channel right
here. Um I don't think this is
necessarily a problem, right? So it's
closing the channel um from S1. Um so
I don't
another message.
Okay, let's say there's another message
here.
Mhm.
So maybe you would
So I would agree that maybe you would
want it to be there, but I don't think
you would end up with an inconsistent
snapshot if it wasn't there.
So
I think that if you so if you do
initiate your if if you do have multiple
initiators I think your snapshot might
uh your snapshot might be might be
smaller than than the ideal right in the
sense that it's going to capture less
right because um because marker messages
arrived arguably faster than they would
have otherwise uh but um but I don't
think that um I don't I but it wouldn't
so even though even though it might be a
smaller snapshot in the sense that it it
captured a kind of a smaller prefix of
event history I don't think it would be
a wrong snapshot
well yeah but when are you ever going to
have a complete snapshot right like
there's there's always going to be uh
like these snapshot there's no guarantee
with this snapshot algorithm that it's
going to the uh like the most up-to-date
snapshot because what does that even
mean? Uh unless you paused everything
and then decided to uh if you paused
everything then you could snapshot
everything that you had. Uh but that
would require you to pause.
So there's another question in chat
which is wouldn't you need an identifier
to figure out which snapshots to group
together? Uh so no I don't think so. I
mean you knew so you know uh so so when
a message arrives you know who it came
from right because you know which
channel it came in on. Um so you know
for example when you see when P1
receives a marker message from P2 it
knows to to close uh its incoming
channel from P2. Uh, and then these
snapshots, the snapshots of the state
that's taken on each process. Uh, well,
you're going to have exactly one of
those for every process, no matter what
you do. Uh, so it's it's not as though
the snapshot on the process gets taken a
second time when you receive the other
initiator. It's just once it's already
there, it's there. Uh so there's there's
no need to then snapshot the state again
uh when you when you receive another
message because it's like this process
as far as it's concerned when it gets
this other message here um it doesn't
know that process 2 was also an
initiator right it just knows that it's
receiving a marker message and then it
just does the standard thing that it
does when it receives a marker message.
uh in this case it's a marker message
and and because it sent this one it it's
the case where you receive a marker
message and you've already seen one uh
so you all are asking really good
questions about this actually um and uh
I know I admit I haven't thought through
all the details um but but in general
this uh uh you might have to trust me
when I say this algorithm has the
property that you can have multiple
initiators um so
I think this is really uh really very
deep, right? The fact that you're that
that this algorithm can run in this in
this uh in this way that doesn't require
the processes to have to agree on who
will be in charge. Um so if somebody
wants to to initiate they just go ahead
and do it and if more than one does then
it's not a problem. So algorithms that
that have this property are called
decentralized algorithms. Um so the
simplest definition there's different
ways to define decentralized right but
the simplest way to define it that I
know um is a decentralized algorithm
uh is one
that can have multiple initiators.
And so by contrast a centralized
algorithm has exactly one initiator.
So the the Chandandy Lamport algorithm
is a decentralized algorithm. Not every
distributed algorithm is but this one
is. Uh and we'll talk about other
decentralized algorithms later on in the
course too.
Okay. So another thing I want to do
before we we move on from discussing
snapshots is just say a little bit more
about why we want to have snapshots in
the first place. Um so we started to
talk about this uh a little bit last
time. Uh but let's let's talk about it a
little bit more. So what's the purpose
of taking a snapshot?
What are snapshots good for? Um, so
here's some ideas.
Checkpointing.
We actually talked about this a little
bit at the beginning of the class um on
uh when we talked about uh HPC uh high
performance computing systems. So some
systems take periodic snapshots of their
state so that if they fail and have to
restart then they have a reasonable
place to start from instead of having to
start from scratch. So a snapshot
algorithm could be used for that.
Um, here's another thing.
Deadlock detection.
So the state of being deadlocked is a
property where once it's true at one
time, it's going to be true from that
point onward as long as the system is
running. So a deadlock would be a
situation where one process is waiting
for another and then that process is
waiting for the first one or maybe you
have a a group of processes that are all
waiting on one another. Um so you can
check for deadlocks by periodically
taking a snapshot and then seeing if
there's a deadlock in the snapshot.
So if a snapshot has a deadlock and the
system is still running then the current
state of the system will also have a
deadlock.
And then more broadly actually um so
generalizing that
detection of any stable property. So a
stable property um is any property of a
system that once it becomes true remains
true from then on.
So deadlocks are actually the the
property the system is deadlocked is an
example of a stable property. So
snapshots can be used not only for
deadlock detection but they can be used
for detecting whether any stable
property of a system is true uh in the
same way that they can be used for
deadlock detection. Um, so another
example of a of a stable property is
the system has finished
doing useful work.
Um,
In other words, termination. Um, so
that's another stable property that we
could detect using snapshots. Uh, we can
take a snapshot and if uh if the if
there's no useful work continuing in the
snapshot. Now, that might that's not
necessarily something like that's
something that might require a human,
right, to know whether it's useful work
or not. Um but uh that's another stable
property that we can detect using
snapshots.
Um so there's a there's a question uh in
chat which is that uh since the
Chandandy Lamport algorithm doesn't work
if the system crashes does that mean we
can't use it for deadlock detection? So
when you say a system crashes and yeah
so I'm guessing you mean a process
crashes. Uh so
let's say you're trying to run the
Chandandy Lamport algorithm and a
process crashes. Well, what you have to
do is start over. So in other words, the
Chandandy Lamport algorithm isn't robust
to a process crashing. Uh so you can use
it. Um so I guess um so
I think maybe
perhaps I I should have used the word
live lock here. Uh but um m maybe maybe
you're conflating deadlock with
crashing. Uh so if a process crashes
while you're trying to take a snapshot,
then either the Chandandy Lamport
algorithm won't terminate, right?
Because um it'll be waiting for a marker
message from that C from that crash
process that will never arrive. Um or I
guess it's it's also possible that the
snapshot will be wrong in some way,
although I haven't uh thought through
the details of that.
But um uh but but I don't I I think
those are those are distinct things. I
don't I I don't think that um that the
requirement that um that processes don't
crash while the snapshot algorithm is
running. I don't think that interferes
with our ability to use snapshots for
deadlock detection.
All right,
so that's about it that I have to say
about uh about Chandandy Lamport. Uh, I
am going to pause now and do a quiz
question.
So, I'm curious about the ratio of
people who are watching on Twitch right
now versus uh watching on Zoom for
people who are enrolled in the class. Um
because it seems like there's uh
Yeah. Okay. So, there's 70 people in the
Zoom meeting right now,
which is the majority of the class. Um,
but I wonder how many people are
actually watching on on Twitch. I've
only talked to a couple of students who
say that they watch on Twitch, but uh
but maybe there's actually a lot and I
just don't realize it.
People are saying that the Twitch v
video is so much better. Isn't that
amazing?
One of my uh incoming grad students
actually uh works at at Twitch. Um and
uh he introduced me to to somebody who
um who I asked to give a a guest lecture
in this class about uh about how Twitch
works. Um and I really wanted to make
that happen and the that person was
enthusiastic about it too. Um, but it
turns out they won't be able to do it uh
until fall. So maybe I'll get uh
somebody from Twitch to come guest
lecture in my graduate distributed
systems course in the fall, which would
be awesome.
Unfortunately, it can't happen this
spring.
So when Twitch reports the number of
viewers, does that include just people
who are watching it in the browser and
not logged into Twitch? I guess it does,
right?
All right,
cool. So, that's like I guess added
together the Zoom plus Twitch, that's
like the whole enrollment for the class.
Um, so assuming that like at least some
percentage of people who who are
enrolled aren't watching. Um, hopefully
other people who are watching on Twitch
are just uh random people from out in
the world. So, hi random people.
All right,
we're going to wait uh
another few seconds and then we're going
to move on to our next topic.
All
right, let's move on.
So
when we started to talk about Chandandy
Lamport, um I I claimed that it had
something to do with causality.
Um so and this set of events that are in
a snapshot uh taken by the Chandandy
Lamport algorithm, they're always going
to make sense with respect to causality.
So here's what that means to be more
precise.
So let's say you have
three processes
and some events
and messages.
The actual
set of events and messages here doesn't
really matter. It's just an example. Um,
so
we're going to define uh a new piece of
terminology here. So, a cut
is
a time
frontier
going across
a Lamport diagram,
dividing it into
past and future.
So, here's an example of a cut.
It's just a dotted line that goes
through here.
So, it cuts across every process at some
point.
So this would be past
and this would be future.
So we say that an event is in the cut if
it's on the past side of the cut.
So for diagrams done the way that I draw
them, that means above the line because
I always draw with time going downward.
Uh so
an event is in the cut if it's on the
past side. The definition of
that term in the cut. So, what do you
think it means for a cut to be
consistent?
So we're going to define consistency
this way.
We'll say
A cut is consistent when
for all the events
say E
that are in the But
if F happened before E,
then F
is also in the cut.
So this is so if we say if f happens
before e for all f um then f is also in
the cut.
So in a consistent cut
you can't have this.
So, if I have something like this,
I couldn't have something like
this as my cut.
Um, right? Because this event here is in
the cut, right? Because it's on the past
side. Um, so this event, if we give
these processes names,
then the event on process 2 is in the
cut, right? Because it's on the past
side of the line. Um but this event over
here is not in the cut because it's on
the future side of the line. Um but it
happened before this event according to
the happens before relation. So this
would be an inconsistent cut.
Um but something like this would be
okay.
So here
the event on process 2 happened after
the event on process one and the cut
that and the then the the message goes
across the cut. So that's actually
allowed
to have a message going across the cut
that way.
So, here's a fact
about the Chandandy Lamport algorithm.
The Chandandy Lamport algorithm
determines
a consistent cut.
So in other words, if you take the set
of events in a Chandandy Laneport
snapshot,
um so the the the snapshot right
consists of snapshots of of states of
the processes and then snapshots of the
channels. So if you take the set of the
events that are in the snapshots of the
states of the processes
and you make a cut
and that set of events is in the cut
then that cut is going to be consistent.
That's what we mean when we say the
Chandandy Lamport algorithm determines a
consistent cut. Um so you can look at
that um in the example that we went
through uh last time for the Chandandy
Lamport algorithm. Uh so this picture
um so we can look at this um and we can
see that there's a consistent cut here.
So
you could draw your cut as a dotted
dotted line across this picture.
Um and we can see that it's a consistent
cut. So in some cases we have messages
that are going across the cut, right? Um
but we don't have any case where there's
a message that happened on the future
side uh that went over to the past side.
Um so we see that it's a consistent cut
and uh and plus um the Chandandy Lamport
AL algorithm has this additional
property such that if there is a message
across the cut from past to future like
here with this H2D here then it's going
to be captured in a channel recording.
Um so the snapshot will in some sense
it'll know about those uh those receive
events as well.
Um, but Chandandy Lamport will always
give us a global snapshot of processes
that corresponds to a consistent cut.
Um, so you might hear somebody say that
the Chandandy Lamport algorithm
is
causally correct
or that the snapshots that it produces
are causally correct.
Oh, a question in chat was how do you
determine where to place the cut? Well,
in the in the line that I just drew
here, um I just did the So, the cut a
cut is just a line that crosses over
every process line at a particular
point. So, I had it cross over every
process line um right after the events
that were in the snapshot of the state
of each process. Uh so I had it here
between B and C because A and B were in
the in the snapshot of the state of
process one and C wasn't. Um and then
here uh this was actually the last event
on this process. So I did it under
there. And then here I was in the
snapshot but J wasn't. So I did it in
between I and J. Um so that's the cut
that's determined by the algorithm. And
then that cut, it's it's a property of
the Chandandy Lamport algorithm that if
you draw that cut, the one that's
determined by the snapshot that was
taken, then it will be a consistent cut.
Okay,
questions about that?
so we have maybe 15 minutes left. Um, I
want to start to uh get ready to move on
to a new topic. Um, in the but in the
time that we have left, we won't have
time to go into a whole lot of detail.
So, let's just recap some of the things
that we've been talking about the last
few days. uh and then we'll be in a good
place to to move on to a new topic uh
next week. Um
so let's let's quickly let's quickly
recap the um the delivery guarantees
that that we've talked about so far and
the protocols that enforce those
guarantees. Um so first one we talked
about is FIFO
of and what does the FIFO guarantee say?
It says
if a process sends
say message M2
after M1,
then
any process
delivering both
delivers M1 first.
And the lamport diagram that illustrates
a violation of this guarantee
would look like this.
So that's a FIFO anomaly.
And what do we do to implement a a FIFO
delivery protocol? Uh we talked about
that a little bit. Um we have a couple
of choices. Um so we could put sequence
numbers on messages, right? Um or we
could require an acknowledgement before
the next send. Uh or both. So, we could
do something like
numbering these messages
and then not delivering them uh uh
unless they're
the next one in the sequence. Or
we could have this back and forth where
acknowledgements are required.
So that's FIFO delivery.
Cool. What about causal delivery? So
what does the causal delivery guarantee
say?
It says that
if the send of message M1
happens before
the send of message M2,
then
the deliver
of M1 happens before the deliver of M2.
And a violation of that guarantee
look like this.
Our classic causal anomaly
What do we do to ensure causal delivery?
Vector clocks or we use some kind of for
this we can use some sort of causal
broadcast algorithm and the causal
broadcast algorithm is is based on
vector clocks. So processes keep track
of their own vector clock. Uh we attach
vector clocks to messages uh when we
send them and before we deliver a
message, we check its vector clock to
make sure it's not from the future.
Uh so that's what you do to enforce
causal delivery at least in a broadcast
setting.
How about totally ordered delivery?
What was the guarantee then?
If a process delivers
M1
then M2
all processes These
delivering both
deliver M1 first.
And here's our
classic picture of what a violation of
totally ordered delivery would look
like.
Did we talk about a protocol that we
could use to enforce totally ordered
delivery?
We did not. We just talked about how it
was hard.
So
that said, here's here's something you
could do, right? Have another process
running over here.
And then anytime remember that we were
talking about these being clients and
these being replicas.
So the idea here is that the clients are
the only ones sending the messages and
the replicas are receiving them.
Uh so I have another process over here.
Um
call it maybe like coordinator.
And anytime a client wants to send a
message, it has to check in with that
process first.
Then that process tells the other
processes the order in which to deliver
the messages. So they all agree. So
these clients would have to first go
over here to say to talk to the coord
process and say hey I want to send a
message and then the coord process would
then manage the sending of that message
to the replicas and same here this would
have to check in here and then messages
would go to here and here.
Okay so that would be one way of
enforcing totally ordered delivery.
What's wrong with doing it that way?
It's slow, right? So, problems with
this,
it's slow. Why is it slow? Because the
coordinator is a bottleneck.
Is there anything else that's wrong with
this?
Yeah. If the coordinator crashes, right?
So this approach isn't great. We'll come
back to this later in the course. I only
draw this picture to demonstrate that it
is possible uh to enforce totally
ordered delivery this way. It's not a
great way though.
So one thing that I want to talk about
in the last five minutes that we have
here. So all these properties that we've
talked about um so we talked about FIFO
delivery um so FIFO delivery causal
delivery
um and then totally ordered delivery
all these prop properties that we've
been talking about
uh these are all specifications of how
some protocol or algorithm should behave
uh and in particular
um they're they're what are called
safety properties. So what does that
mean? So any property that we talk about
um can be thought of as a
safety property
or a livveness property.
or some combination of the two.
So what do those terms mean? What is a
safety property?
Um so colloally a safety property tells
you that
something bad
won't happen.
So we know that a property is a safety
property if we can point at something
that violates it in a finite execution.
So for example,
this is a finite execution
that violates the FIFO delivery
property.
Well, these lines go on forever. Um, so
maybe it's not finite the way that I
drew it, but we could make a cut
right here, look at the events and
messages that are in the cut and then
say that's a violation of of FIFO
delivery. So we know that FIFO delivery
is a safety property um, if we can point
at something that violates it in a
finite execution.
What about what about causal delivery?
Is that one a safety property also?
Sure,
we could violate causal delivery and
infinite execution.
totally
ordered delivery, same deal. So the fact
that all of these properties can be
violated in a finite execution means
that they're safety properties.
Aliveness property, on the other hand,
says
something good
eventually happens.
So an example of a livveness property uh
would be something like uh the system
eventually responds to every client
request.
Um so if you have an execution like
this,
say you have a client
and then a system
and then a request.
So let's pretend that the system is just
one process right now. In reality, it
might be many. Um here's a request.
Time goes by here, right?
Crickets are chirping.
Does this execution violate the property
that the system responds to every client
request? What do you think?
Yeah. No, not if it not if eventually
has no time limit, right? So the
property hasn't been violated yet. So
livveness properties do not have finite
counter examples. In other words, I
can't draw a picture of a finite
execution that violates a livveness
property. I can draw lots of finite
executions that satisfy the livveness
property, but I can't draw a picture of
a finite execution that violates it. And
livveness properties are usually
considered harder to reason about than
safety properties.
And the trouble is you really need both,
right? Uh so we're out of time. Uh so
we'll begin talking about this more next
week. Um and then we're going to this is
going to lead us into our next topic uh
which is going to start to talk about uh
fault models and failure. See you next
time.